am i supposed to understand surprise as
equivalent to a mismatch between what
you predict and what actually happens
so error right that's an excellent
is it more complex than that well it's
um
if you want to get into the nitty-gritty
so
surprise read as surprisal is um
a very simple concept concept it's just
the self-information it's
the negative log probability of some
outcome
uh usually a sensory state of of your
markov blanket
so if something is highly improbable or
if the outcome or your sensory state say
your physiological
sensed physiological state is higher
likely given what you are
so the usual example here is the fish
out of out of water for example
that that has a lot of surprise um it
just means it's just a you know
a euphemism for for self-information
that scores
the kinds of outcomes that um
would be characteristic of this
self-organizing system
so it's just a way of writing down um or
scoring the probability of being in this
state
if you're that kind of system or um
technically if
you're um you have that
that kind of pullback attractor
there's another kind of surprise um
which is the bayesian surprise
which is often confused with that which
is i think closer
um to the notion that we're just talking
about which is the degree to which
something
causes me to change my mind the
information gain
um which is the complexity so
the complexity basically when you
um if you're looking at this as a
statistician you're given some data and
you had some prior beliefs about
what caused those data before you saw
the data and then you use
bayes rule to combine
the likelihood of those of those data
given your beliefs about how the cause
with your prize
you can't be the posterior so posterior
after seeing the data this is now your
belief so you start with your prior
belief and then you have your
posterior belief and then there's a
movement
and that movement is this kl divergence
that we're talking about
that scores the amount you've changed
your mind that just
is the complexity um it's the complexity
cost that you have paid
for providing a more accurate account or
an accurate account of the data
that you've explained that has moved
your beliefs from priors
to to posteriors so it is the
the cost of um
changing beliefs in order
to do belief updating on bayesian belief
updating
i'm going on about that because it's
clearly quite interesting that because
you know
via things like landauer's principle and
the jozinski
equality that degree of movement costs
thermodynamic energy
so that tells you that a
good artifact a good person or a good
computer
um from the point of view of existential
goodness as
scored by minimizing free energy or
maximizing
marginal likelihood or moral evidence is
the kind
of personal computer or artifact that
when confronted with some new
information
will actually process and assimilate
that in a really thermodynamically
efficient way
so they'll do it with a very cool brain
they won't use very much electricity or
food
and very little will change and what
that basically means is
their prior beliefs were already quite
close to the posterior beliefs
so they already had a good idea of
what's going on so they were not
surprised so
and in not being surprised or trying to
minimize that complexity cost in
in terms of the price you have to pay
for providing an
accurate account of some data um
you're you are you you are also
maximizing the efficiency of
of of your belief updating so i think
that's quite a nice thing because what
it says is you're going to build
good artifacts good artificial general
intelligence
what you're looking for is a really
small
thing that can be powered with a battery
that's
the one that's the kind of thing that'll
do the best kind of belief updating
that's very tailor-made
for the imprints problem uh inference
problem at hand
so that's a we wanted away from your
question about what surprises but the
other
surprise is just basically the impromptu
implausibility of this happening to me
basically
when you were talking about what makes a
good computer or a good person
and you're using good in a different
manner i assume you're using it in terms
of
adaptive or or effective or accurate or
at least
not using too much energy to accomplish
its tasks
that to me sounds like almost a
restatement of occam's razor that you
want the minimal assumptions to account
for the most data is that similar or no
oh no it's exactly the same thing so
that's excellent yeah no that that's
things exactly so
you know the the the pressure to provide
a simple account
of the uh of the data is exactly getting
this um
paying the least complexity cost
possible for the ac for the accurate or
the fitting
and um and that is exactly okam's
principle
and if you don't know that that's
important and that's probably more
important than the accurate fitting
then you will end up with machine
learning
artifacts and devices and schemes that
overfit
and if they overfit they don't um try to
minimize the complexity
of um the uh the explanation at hand or
you know that effectively their
inference
then you will get a an inference
and learning that does not generalize so
inevitably if you allow
for overfitting then you overfit today's
data
and tomorrow's data are very difficult
to explain because you've over explained
today's data
so just practically what this manifests
as is a problem of sharp minima
in difficult to solve optimization
problems
in machine learning you get stuck
in local minima that have a very very sh
difficulty yeah and and that's because
you you haven't you haven't flattened
the minima
by building into your objective function
this
simplifying um aspect this
complexity suppressing aspect and of
course once you
have an objective function which
actually
entails that complexity minimizing um
imperative then the minima by definition
the free energy minima are always
shallow
so that you've got a lot of latitude to
wander around your minima so you're not
committing to a particular sharp
explanation for over explaining the data
so
it's a really practically really
important you know observation though
i should say that when i talk about good
i just mean minimizing free energy or
maximizing evidence
so so that's the only
which is you know fit for purpose in
this world having a good model of this
of this particular world